14 months ago you went on the air and
called the Tea Party the American
Taliban I did what happened that a lot
the second season of Aaron Sorkin's the
newsroom is premiering on July
fourteenth and if it's anything like the
first season the scathing commentary on
the state of journalism today will be
unrelenting and painful there are five
reasons why the show is an insult to
journalism new media should be
celebrated not treated with contempt the
show vilifies new media as the anchor
will McAvoy is extremely reluctant to
adapt to the times and is bitterly
reverential about the good old days when
you could only get three versions of the
news journalists are not the
intellectual elite wellness team think
that he is God's greatest gift to
mankind and that his viewpoint is beyond
reproach and therefore doesn't offer
contending views good journalists
actually work hard and are committed to
reporting the news night team doesn't
see a need to go out and get stories the
reporters rely primarily on luck and
pre-existing knowledge there's always
bias in the media you just need to be
upfront about it well claims to be a
Republican but his story choice
indicates the opposite included but not
limited to repeatedly claiming that the
Tea Party is taking over the world
journalists do make mistakes and they
should take responsibility for them well
actually does apologize but only on
behalf of the journalism industry of
which he believes he has risen above
maybe we should look to other fictional
newscasters as role models take
anchorman's Ron Burgundy for example
burgundy goes out into the field and
ends up getting the greatest story of
the year the story of a panda giving
birth he doesn't just sit by and rely on
chance to get the scoop and he does not
pretend to be anything other than the
lovable imbecile that he is I'm good to
do the thing that God put Ron Burgundy
on this earth to do
have salon-quality hair and read the
news friesen TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer